baby Afra is being welcomed into her new
home her parents and siblings died when
the Quake struck her uncle Khalil wanted
to take her in right away but it took
several days before she was allowed to
join his household now she's back with
family sitting alongside khalil's own
newborn daughter
Afra was born under the rubble she was
at the hospital and we received her
today she is in good condition the
reason behind the delay receiving her is
that we were asked for some legal
procedures by the officials in the area
and they checked that we were her
relatives
Afra was found under the ruins of her
family's home in jandiris she was
apparently born under the rubble her
umbilical cord still connecting her to
her dead mother
despite the loss of all her immediate
family after his discovery made her a
symbol of Hope as Rescuers search for
survivors
genderis is one of the towns that was
worst hit by the earthquake as the U.N
Convoy of more than 140 trucks full of
Aid arrived in Northwest Syria officials
made a point of visiting there I'm
shocked by the scale that destruction
I've never seen anything like it in all
my life there's huge needs obviously
particular shelter and also people need
fresh water they have medical needs
and you know we need to scale up the
responses
as survivors of the Quake wait for the
help they need they'll have to rely on
each other more than ever Finton Monahan
Al Jazeera